I'm actually gonna use my arm so I can
high-five so many people 106
you're gonna high-five a hundred and six
people yeah aren't you gonna get tired
no because because my real arms gonna do
all the work Alex was born without a
fully formed arm a condition that
affects around 1,500 babies born in the
US every year I'm here to see him get
fitted with a new arm we have come a
long way in the development of
prosthetic limbs you might think of the
earliest prosthetic as maybe a peg leg
for a sailor but it actually dates back
much further than that
in fact over 3,000 years ago to ancient
Egypt the thought was that our lives
have a finite length but that the
afterlife is eternal and according to
the theology of Osiris the body needed
to be complete because the soul would
leave the body in theory and every night
come back to replenish its energy in the
body and it was so important that that
body be full and so there are many
instances of prosthetic noses ears toes
and limbs which were used in ancient
Egypt to ensure that the body was
complete but a lot of those prosthetics
weren't actually functional so
prosthetics developed from simply being
aesthetic aids to actually becoming
functional globally there are an
estimated 3 million people living
without an upper limb over the last 10
to 20 years we've seen remarkable
advancement in the development of bionic
limbs the problem with these prosthesis
is they typically cost on the order of
20 to $100,000 now here at UCF they are
building an arm which can be used and
manufactured for much much cheaper like
1% of that cost
how did you get inspired to design an
arm for children and I was listening to
the radio and there was an interview
with the person who developed the first
3d printed hand
I went into my research lab and I said
you know I have to get part of this what
can I do at home and then we had Alex's
parents contact us directly saying can
you build our summit arm the arm itself
is completely 3d printed and so are the
joints between the fingers so there's a
cable which runs down the length of each
finger and back into the hand they would
normally be connected up to this servo
motor here and the idea is to trigger
this motor via the arm of the person
who's wearing it so they would wear
three electrodes on their upper arm when
the person wearing the arm squeezes
their muscle there's a little electrical
pulse which triggers this motor to pull
in 180 degrees one pulse will close the
hand like this and then another pulse or
relax it so it opens back up our arm
provides a level of self-confidence to
the children but whenever they're going
to school there's questions asked like
what happened to your arms you get bit
by a shark or run over by a car or
something after we gave them the arm it
quickly changed to oh that's a cool arm
how's it worth where'd you get it I
actually bring it to school so so I can
actually do other stuff
3d printing is relatively new technology
but it provides us a low-cost solution
to be able to create things so we can
print something out and say it doesn't
work redesign it and print it out again
the next day we produce our arm for just
about three hundred dollars now whereas
some of the prosthetics on the market
can go upwards of 40,000 dollars
insurance companies typically don't want
to pay for it for kids because every six
months are going to replace it as the
kid grows but this allows us to be able
to reproduce an arm for about maybe a
hundred dollars and just print out
anyone how important is the aesthetic
design the artistic design of the arm we
want to make sure the kid is expressing
himself or herself what the arm
self-expression for a kid is very
important we have one sleeve right here
this one is actually keen to run the
Disney movie Tangled
we provided this for a little girl named
Madeline the design is so simple that it
is easy to print out on location and put
together even with very little technical
knowledge and also the functionality of
the design with only three electrodes
activating the one servo make it so that
people can learn to use it very quickly
and that
think is what makes it so powerful you
got have any luck there 50/50 50/50 all
right I excited right now
about trying out and how to do
somersaults and do some things I never
done before I want to play new game flip
it and hooker two hands how have you
been able to crack this problem that
other people haven't before we have an
incredible team of very diverse
backgrounds and so bringing all of our
common experience together we were able
to find this type of solution where our
main base is in Orlando Florida at the
University of Central Florida we have
our designers in California I'm here in
Germany and everywhere in between
we have people trying to help us and
support our project although it's
challenging we're making it work a lot
of our communication comes through
Microsoft OneNote and we use this
product to be able to share information
through each other specifically since
Albert is in Germany that's a whole
ocean away I think that you can edit it
from anywhere in the world and have it
simultaneously update and anyone else on
the project so being able to get updates
from my team and see the progress
they're making enables me to help do my
job here in Germany what is the
collective project Microsoft is looking
for students who are wanting to impact
their community with great ideas and
they're looking to rally their
communities and the world around them to
help bring it like our biggest needs
right now is one we need funding we we
need more donations to be able to make
this a reality and make these children's
dreams come true you want to provide
free arms to every kid who needs one
absolutely we don't feel like people
should profit from a childhood without
an arm if they want to help with design
they're more than welcome to join our
project and be designing arms they can
be putting out arms and everything fit
them for their local community where
they can just send us
now the best tailor these for the future
we can eat up we can use all that hope
we can get
where do you want to see the limitless
arm go my hope for the future is to be
able to increase the functionality of
the arms to encompass maybe an elbow or
even an upper limb socket and then be
able to produce this on a larger scale
for as many children in the world
competed as each child comes to us we
really understand and appreciate the
need for the readily adaptable readily
deployable solution to each individual
and unique biology we're trying to get
an elbow going for Alex so you have not
only hand movement but you can also move
the elbow as well to overcome that we
have to make this also bigger to be able
to put another servo in there we like
ideas we're not just this is our way
this is how it has to be it's anything's
possible
we'd like to broaden our field as well I
think we're just at the beginning of
something really great and I hope that
with a little bit of help we're gonna be
able to take this to the UN and UNICEF
and really impact children all over the
world thank you guys for making this big
porky for me that's fantastic thank you
so much for chatting to me thank you
you're very welcome this video was
supported by Microsoft OneNote in their
collective project they have identified
student groups around the country who
are working together using their
software in order to change the world
and the whole point of the collective
project is to bring people together and
you can get involved as well by clicking
on the link in the description you could
help by providing new designs for arms
by helping with software or even 3d
printing in your own community and that
will help get more of these arms out to
the kids who need them so I really want
you to get involved check out the link
in the description